they called it in your era of the Three
Kingdoms as the leaders of China and
Japan and South Korea met for talks but
the one leader setting the agenda at the
summit was not at the table North
Korea's Kim jong-un
after the latest tests at the missile
launch site earlier this month regional
powers are concerned Pyongyang is about
to undo efforts to ease tensions we
agreed that peace on the Korean
Peninsula was in the common interest of
the three countries we also agreed to
make efforts together to help promote
North Korea us dialogue for
denuclearization and peace the
possibility of North Korea turning into
a serious nuclear threat has become more
tangible after February summit between
Kim and US president Donald Trump failed
to deliver any results the common threat
of a North Korean attack has forced
Japan in South Korea to overcome their
own bilateral tensions over their
colonial history I am willing to improve
this important relationship between
Japan and South Korea by all means today
I would like to have a frank discussion
China North Korea's only Ally supports
the call for peace on the Korean
Peninsula Beijing is interested in
easing tensions in the region also for
economic reasons China's premier used
the opportunity to promote a new free
trade zone between the three countries
the prospect of more diplomatic and
economic unity in East Asia is cause for
optimism but the dawn of a new era
depends on substantial achievements
after the talks
and for more on this I'm joined down the
studio by Fabian kuchma who's based in
Beijing at Fabian nice words from these
leaders what chances of any kind of
change in the situation well there won't
be any major breakthrough I mean you
said it nice works it was a symbolic
message an important message that you
know all will work together towards
peace and denuclearization and they want
to increase the communication towards
North Korea however in North Korea is
not really looking towards communication
they've been really silent towards any
diplomatic offer what they want is
really clear they want economic
concessions they want the sanctions
against them lifted and that's something
that the US and also the international
community the UN Security Council can
provide because absent from the table is
the United States which is really the
big source of the conflict the Americans
want North Korea to denuclearize North
Korea wants the Americans to stop
sanctions with nobody giving ground what
chance is there of any kind of deal or
forward movement I mean right now it
looks very bleak but I'm just a couple
of days ago and China actually made an
interesting proposal they wanted or they
suggested that parts of the sanctions
against North Korea would be lifted they
argue that some of the sanctions not
only hurt the elite which is a desirable
effect but also I'm having the lives of
the common people and also they want to
kick-start the negotiations by you know
having sanctions partially lifted
however I don't see the u.s. agreeing to
that because it counters their
perspective they want denuclearization
first and if you give North Korea any
kind of concession economically then you
know they lack incentive to basically
dismantle the nuclear program it's kind
of interesting to see these three
countries coming together though as
there are some disagreements quite apart
from North Korea particularly between
Japan and South Korea do you think the
fact of actually meeting will help
dialog improve in other domains yeah
definitely I mean South Korean president
moon jae-in and japanese prime minister
shinzo abba they met for the first time
for talks and over 15 months and i mean
we know that Japan also had similar
historic issues with China I mean it's
all about the Japan's colonial past and
China in Japan they have basically
overcome they are historical dispute and
I think South Korea could learn from
this example however the sentiment
against Japan is much more deeply rooted
and more emotional among the South
Korean population and of course in China
you have a more top-down approach in
South Korea it's a democracy and you
cannot really you know change the
sentiment that fast
okay Fabian catch breath thanks for that
insight